fundraising event that raises crucial
funds for Cleveland Clinic Lou rouvo
Center for brain health to provide
quality care resources and more to
patients and their caregivers as they
fight brain diseases and here to tell us
more about the 26th annual Power of Love
Gala is Dr Dylan nguyint the director of
the Cleveland Clinic Lou rouvo Center
for brain health it's so good to have
you on the show thank you it's great to
be here this is an amazing event 26
years you guys have been doing tell us
about I want to talk about the event and
it's amazing but tell us about where the
money goes that is raised for this yeah
absolutely so the money that we raise at
the event goes to support the care that
patients get at our Center we also use
it to support care that we give to the
community so we have lots of no cost
education and support that we give to
people who are suffering from
neurodegenerative diseases as well as
the families of those who have
neurodegenerative diseases these are
given free to the community and um The
Power of Love Gala funds go to help
support that and you really have a lot
of star power backing you guys up for
the Power of Love gala this year tell us
a little bit about who we can expect
this year yeah well there will be
appearances by uh Sammy Hagar Alice
Cooper John Mayer Paula Abdul
um I don't want I don't want to keep
going because I'm going to certainly
miss me there's so many people it is a
star-studded Gala but you're also going
to be paying tribute to some very
special people too it sounds like yeah
that's right so this Gala will take
place on the 27th anniversary of Lou
rouvo's passing and John Paul dejoria
who handed Larry Ruvo the check that got
all of this started we'll be honored
with our community leadership award and
we'll also uh be be honoring David hum
who was Las Vegas who became a Raider
and unfortunately developed multiple
sclerosis but we call him the original
Las Vegas Raider and we'll be honoring
his fight and his family's fight against
multiple sclerosis as we try to raise
awareness for uh for the programs that
we have in multiple sclerosis as well he
was really wonderful man I know the hum
family and his daughter is just fabulous
and I am so happy that you guys are
going to be honoring him it's going to
be a great event how do people be a part
of this how do they get tickets yeah so
tickets are available at keep memory
alive backslash Pol standing for Power
of Love okay tickets are still available
there for everyone who who wants to
attend well thank you for all that you
do over there at the Cleveland Clinic it
is truly amazing how you're helping
these people and the caregivers too
because we so often forget about those
caregivers so thank you so much for
joining us today doctor thank you never
forget about caregivers absolutely not
keep memory alive is hosting that 26th
annual Power of Love Gala on Saturday
February the 18th at the MGM Grand
Garden Arena and if you'd like to get
tickets you can go to keep